hello there
it's time for yet another myth chaser
episode as the fort nightmares update
has brought
so many new things for us to test and
lightly break
together if you haven't seen this series
before or need a refresher
myth chasers takes the questions you
leave in the comments below
and tests them out in game so please
throw a thumbs up on the myths you like
and we'll test them
next time this week midas reawoke
on br island and as we received so many
requests
to see my despite other bosses i've
mashed all them
into one episode a single video
hopefully in 10 minutes
you'll get the answers to all those
questions so slap code adamaru in the
store to support this series
and let's get to some boss on boss
action
here's the map right now and all the
locations of the current fortnight
bosses
our job today is to take midas to all
these points
for him to face off with doctor doom
wolverine
iron man and the henchman bill and ted
we spent a whole day getting this
footage by the way and solving these
myths so let's see how many you can
predict
let's save bill and ted for last because
that's the best one so our next decision
is who shall midas face first
we decided dr doom would be his premier
opponent
we began and this is when we found our
first issue
midas will not leave his island for
anyone and every time he's thrown from
it
he always runs back as quick as he can
we needed a plan
i called upon my discord and recruited
people in chat
our 200 iq brain decided to make a
tunneled bridge
all the way from the authority to the
football pitch
the soccer field which is now open at
doom's domain where the green goliath is
currently waiting to do battle
going from here to here no easy feat
this is how it went down
the bridge worked like a dream it even
had badass struts
a great feat of engineering and windows
to monitor midas progress
midas was being led over the lake with
only fishing rods
bouncers and the occasional wall we were
all ecstatic but of course
things don't always go to plan and
suddenly midas escaped the tunnel and
attempted to run
back home we sprang into action and for
the first 35 minutes
yep over over half an hour we pulled
blocked pushed
and fished him over to the first boss
battle of the season
this was a grueling task but working
together we got midas
to the underground arena he broke out
about six times but each time we dragged
him back in until the final issue
only two tiles away from the fight we
didn't calculate that doom would
actually help midas
his bolt attack transferring through
many of us allowing midas to escape
yet again but that's not the end of this
story as doom waited below we dropped
midas into his secret bunker
immediately doom hit midas with the
sweatiest aoe attack you've ever seen
but midas didn't even pay attention he
brushed it off he didn't care who doom
was
he was fixated on returning home and
that's when he made a rookie mistake
trying to escape through the vault which
was shut firmly
for all he tried he was now stuck and
although doom's accuracy was like mine
this fight took forever and but
eventually
doom prevailed midas was vaporized and
without blinking
doom turned his eyes to us so we
bum-rushed him
because that's how we roll on my discord
afterwards we celebrated this was a long
time coming but we did it
and we now know if midas visits doom's
domain he ain't gonna survive
i wondered if we should try this in
reverse would midas win
on his own turf what do you reckon
finally the cool kids climbed on the
highest building to celebrate
and danced for a while and i was stuck
on my own one day i'll be a cool kid
like those
anyway next myth so who shall midas
fight next
how about iron man this time we wanted
to make it a little fairer on midas who
is programmed to run home
even when in a fight we chose a spot in
between iron man and
midas and attempted to get both there
we quickly found that iron man is
impossible to cage in due to his unibeam
attacks
so we let him take the ground below
stark industries
then it was a case of getting midas
there it was a little easier than
getting him to doom's domain so he
didn't need the tunneled bridge
technique
it was messy though look at this we got
carried away and covered far too much of
the water but i
strangely find this satisfying i digress
over time midas was pulled over to the
man of iron but it quickly became
apparent
he didn't want to fight today always
running away
and then every time we got him close
enough iron man would evaporate half our
squad
but like always we kept going and
madison iron man
locked eyes and began to fight
[Music]
it was ultra one-sided with midas only
firing three or four times
while iron man hit midas with multiple
unibeams
midas was far too defensive and
constantly ran
backwards this wasn't even a fight but
then something changed in midas
he stopped running away and decided to
get involved in the fight
standing his ground and tanking another
blast but this was too little
too late midas was defeated for a second
time today
i hate to say this but midas may be the
weakest boss in fortnite
oh and if you're wondering we bum-rushed
iron man again and
decided to do the conga in celebration
this time happy days
so let's address the elephant in the
room wolverine
it's now his turn to face midas and to
give midas the best chance possible
we decided to bring wolverine up to the
ruins and give midas home advantage
i think you can already guess what's
going to happen here here we go
[Music]
this time midas stood his ground right
away hitting wolverine with shots before
the wood wanderer
even caught his scent but then logan
took the battle to midas
and the two fought hard midas landed
quality shots but wolverine's healing
ability and those special attacks
were too much for the new boss at the
ruins wolverine wins
we tried to dance with the victor but he
was having none of it so instead for
good measure we took wolverine to face
iron man and doctor doom again
he still wipes the floor with them
completely was this the end of our boss
fight
well there is another set of bosses
which are stronger than wolverine
the mighty henchman bill and ted
if you watched the last myth chaser
episode you'll have seen the henchmen
destroy wolverine multiple times
so we took wolverine all the way over to
sweaty sands
for a rematch would we get the same
result this time around
and it's the strangest thing ever they
no longer acknowledge each one exists
it's really weird i think it's because
the henchmen know they are supreme
and eventually the henchman will
actually help wolverine attack
and back up this boss it's really
strange at one point wolverine ran away
and the henchmen kept fighting even
killing a few of us before going back
into passive mode again and walking away
so there's obviously been a change to
the ai here so that means
we have one set of bosses left for midas
to face
midas versus the henchman for the title
of toughest sop
in fortnite think he's got a chance me
me neither right away we knew this was a
huge task
as we'd never got a boss this far across
the map before still standing
and once again i need to thank my
discord peeps as this myth took over an
hour to bring to fruition
let's do this from sweaty sands to the
ruins is a long
long long ass way this is how far it is
between sweaty sands and the authority
of the ruins
this one took thousands of pieces of
wood brick and metal with a dedicated
bunch of folks
frantically building editing fishing and
well bickering we did we did fell out a
few times
eventually we arrived and set up a way
to force midas and the henchmen
to interact with each other we took the
boss to the taco stand
we know this is the favorite place of
the henchmen
when we fenced in midas he accidentally
shot bill
or ted i don't actually know which one
is which to be honest
this shot was heard around the world and
both henchmen
whipped out their pieces and began
trading shots with midas
this is now midas fourth fight and he's
slowly learning that running away
is not the best option and for the first
section of this battle
midas is on top landing more shots than
his opponents
suddenly though midas went back to his
old ways he began to move away
and this became a genius move this
action forced the white henchmen to
pursue
and look at what happens when he comes
round the corner
a deadly digital bullet midas had
finally done it he'd eliminated a boss
but now the other henchman ted or is it
bill
i have no idea at all he was out for
vengeance pursuing midas who continued
to dodge and weave and back up and try
to go home
at one point illegally running through
someone's house
but we came here for an outcome so we
boxed in the last two bosses
for the final face-off of the episode
and this
happened
[Music]
midas won the face-off with not one but
two bosses in fortnite at the same time
what an absolute legend come on be
honest did anyone guess that he'd win
i sure didn't think he had a chance once
this battle was over we took stock of
the one hour and 20 minute journey we
just went on to check this myth out
building the community emblem hot watch
on top of the ruins
damn that was fun so that's this week's
myth chaser episode what do you think i
hope you enjoyed it
we'll go back to normal random things
next time around so please use the
comments below for any myths you'd like
us to test
on screen now are the people who made
these crazy myths possible to pull off
those who use my code adamaru in the
store thanks for sticking with me
i truly appreciate you i'm adam from
playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time